[Musique]
je vous propose maintenant deux
témoignages de deux jeunes femmes qui
ont grandi et qui vivent toujours à son
Cloud des vignes dans le quartier de la
douille
[Musique]
ouvrir une nouvelle séquence témoignage
absolument avec deux invités qu'on est
ravis de recevoir dans leur dame bonjour
bonjour j'ai des deux invités c'est de
vous êtes deux enfants si je peux dire
de Chanteloup et vous allez parler
justement de cette offense passer au
chant Claude ce qui a changé dans ce
paysage dans vos vies dans notre vous
êtes étudiante
en DUT de technique de commercialisation
à Cergy-Pontoise c'est ça
[Musique]
dans les enfin sur les deux collèges de
fréquenter les deux collèges et par la
suite j'ai été au lycée à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine donc en au
lycée général en seconde générale et
suite à cela je me suis enfin en étude
supérieure je suis partie un petit peu
plus loin parce que j'avais envie de
voir autre chose j'ai été jusqu'à
Sarcelles et j'ai suivi des études en
commerce international
alors moi je suis né en 2003 donc ça
fait pas très longtemps effectivement
je suis à Chanteloup depuis toujours
donc moi j'habite aussi dans le quartier
de la Noé juste derrière la crèche et
j'ai aussi fait ma scolarité ici donc
l'école maternelle et élémentaire à
Arthur Rimbaud et j'ai fait le collège
René Cassin et suite à cela je suis
allée au lycée à Poissy moi pas à
Conflans au Corbusier où j'ai fait un
bac général aussi et là maintenant je
suis à l'Université de Cergy alors cet
enfant dans ce quartier dans ce quartier
racontez-nous qu'est-ce qui vous a
marqué par exemple final alors moi ce
qui m'a marqué c'est vrai que c'est la
diversité en tout cas des populations
qui sont représentées moi c'est vrai
qu'il faut savoir que mes parents sont
enfin mon père et arrivés dans les
années 60 en France
on a été élevé
par nos parents en tout cas au contact
de population diverses et variées ce qui
a je pense aussi forgé notre
identité donc c'est vrai que c'est très
important en tout cas de de pas oublier
toutes ces choses là on a fréquenté
l'école publique on a vu évoluer le
quartier donc évoluer avec la rénovation
urbaine donc c'est vrai que ce sont
différentes phases parce que quand vous
arrivez dans les années 80 on est pas
80-90 ça a été les années un peu plus
difficiles peut-être pour chanter la
petite perso moi je l'ai pas senti comme
ça parce que vraiment il y avait
vraiment si vous voulez cette solidarité
quand même entre entre les uns et les
autres donc ça c'est quand même quelque
chose qui était qui était assez
remarquable et moi j'ai des amis
d'enfance que j'ai encore aujourd'hui
que je garde et c'est vrai qui a une il
y a une relation de proximité en tout
cas qui se lit entre les uns et les
autres qui est pas négligeable donc
comment vous viviez vous à l'époque le
votre environnement comment qu'elle
regarde vous aviez sur sur votre
environnement à ce moment-là
le regard que j'avais je pense que c'est
celui du d'une enfant qui qui évolue
dans un dans un environnement qui est
assez qui est assez vaste et variée
après c'est vrai que je trouvais qu'il y
avait des choses qui manquaient quand
même au niveau des des équipements mais
bon ça c'est dû à la à la à la
conception et à la taille de la ville
j'imagine et c'est bien pour ça que pour
faire les études supérieures par exemple
moi j'ai fait le choix en tout cas de de
m'éloigner un petit peu même si j'avais
pu partir à par exemple
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour faire mon BTS
comme la santé internationale mais
j'avais envie de voir autre chose en
fait et ce qui explique le fait que je
ne suis pas mise de barrière si vous
voulez et au même titre que quand j'ai
dû faire mon BTS en commerce
international j'étais consciente qu'il
fallait deux langues donc l'anglais et
l'espagnol moi c'est ce sont des langues
que j'ai j'aimais beaucoup et j'avais
l'obligation en tout cas de faire un
stage à l'étranger donc ce stage à
l'étranger c'est vrai que je vous cache
pas que c'était une période quand même
qui était assez difficile parce que
j'avais pas de réseau et en fait on
arrive là vous avez pas de réseau et en
fait c'est une rencontre fortuite
vraiment par pur hasard dans le RER B
qui a fait que j'ai trouvé un stage en
fait à l'étranger et j'ai pu aller au
États-Unis à New York donc de Chanteloup
à New York moi je trouve que c'est quand
même un grand pas mal donc
j'ai une question justement parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de il y a l'image des
quartiers qui pèse souvent quand on va à
Paris qui pèse moins quand on va à New
York parce que New York ils savent pas
ce que c'est chanteloupe donc non ils
savent pas ce que c'est mais je veux
dire il y a autre chose aussi je veux
dire New York qui est assez ghetto il y
a aussi des ghettos à New York il y a
pas que Time Square donc l'envers du
décor on le voit on le voit très très
vite quand on va dans certains quartiers
comme le Bronx ou comme le Queens est
mort en l'occurrence j'étais dans le
Bronx j'ai j'ai été je me suis vite fait
acclimater peut-être parce que j'ai
peut-être trouvé des similitudes mais
finalement je me dis que en France on
est peut-être pas c'est pas plus mal
parce que le rêve américain en fait
c'est bien dans les films c'est bien
pour les vacances mais pour y vivre il y
a il y a une contrainte en fait il y a
des choses qui il y a des avantages
qu'on a ici et qu'on a pas là-bas si on
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau de la santé je
pense que le problème de santé il est il
est très important et la couverture la
couverture médicale
[Musique]
et plus facile en tout cas ici et
accessible surtout en tant que jeune
femme est-ce que
sur la question de la sécurité est-ce
que vous êtes toujours santé en sécurité
ici est-ce que parfois il y a eu des des
choses un peu plus difficile à vivre
personnellement si je dois me prononcer
par rapport à ça c'est vrai que sur
Chanteloup je me sens quand même plutôt
en sécurité parce que il faut pas se
mentir c'est un quartier assez petit
donc en fait la plupart des gens se
connaissent et on a en fait ce sentiment
de solidarité on se dit qu'on se connaît
tous on est un peu comme une grande
famille en fait donc forcément on se
sent en sécurité on sait que juste en
regardant à droite à gauche on va voir
quelques personnes qu'on connaît donc ça
devrait aller et c'est parce qu'on a en
dehors de Chanteloup quoi quand on sort
ou quand on va sur Paris on sent que
c'est complètement différent
c'est marrant d'ailleurs parce que plus
inquiète à Paris qu'avec qu'ici quoi
largement alors justement c'est parce
que souvent les gens ont un regard sur
les quartiers en disant que c'est archi
dangereux moi je veux pas habiter là-bas
et en fait quand vous habitez un
quartier vous êtes beaucoup plus en
sécurité dans ces quartiers là que quand
vous allez dans le 16e arrondissement
parce que même ici c'est comme ça parce
que quand quelqu'un même si quelqu'un
vous vous agresse ici il y aura toujours
quelqu'un pour vous défendre
alors que quand vous êtes ailleurs c'est
encore autre chose donc il y a quand on
parle de d'image des quartiers c'est
aussi ça c'est ce fantasme qui est
véhiculé par certains et c'est bien que
que vous en témoignez et puis je pense
que au-delà de ça c'est peut-être aussi
de stéréotype et de c'est la perception
en fait oui donc je demande parce que il
y a peut-être justement ce que je pose
des gens je pense qu'il peut être qui
vient de l'externe et c'est sûr que on
va pas avoir le même regard qu'une
personne qui a grandi en fait au cœur de
ce quartier qui se dit que finalement
non il y a des choses qui se font il y a
des choses qui se font bien on a un
tissu associatif qui est indéniable qui
est qui a joué un rôle majeur en tout
cas pendant toute cette pandémie et
au-delà de ça je pense que la solidarité
elle s'est vraiment fait avec tous les
acteurs c'est pas ça c'est pas fait de
chacun de son côté il y a des gens qui
étaient confrontés je pense aussi à la
fracture numérique qui ont pu être aidés
donc ça c'est quand même important aussi
de le souligner donc vous Derrick c'est
des quartiers dans lequel il y a une
façon
de rencontrer d'autres gens qui venaient
d'autres communautés d'ailleurs et vous
avez senti
aussi ah oui oui totalement
finalement parce que je dis ça parce que
il y a 10 ans enfin il y a un petit
écart entre deux donc c'est ça aurait pu
changer il y a 20 ans à peu près voilà
et ce que je voudrais souligner c'est ce
qu'il faut pas oublier en tout cas c'est
que il y a aussi il y a de la précarité
donc oui il y a des il y a il y a la
précarité donc ça c'est des choses qu'il
faut pas oublier il y a des gens
invisibles des personnes qu'on voit pas
et aujourd'hui en tout cas notre action
sociale elle est elle est elle est elle
est beaucoup elle est très dirigée en
tout cas voilà sur la solidarité très
accès là-dessus et je pense qu'on était
voilà on a on a su montrer qu'on savait
faire même si on n'a pas beaucoup de
moyens donc voilà ça c'est des choses à
à mettre en évidence en tout cas sur le
regard justement que que les autres
peuvent avoir peuvent poser sur les gens
qui sont qui sont qui viennent de ces
quartiers ou qui viennent de chanteloups
par exemple pour vous est-ce que vous
avez été confronté
lors de recherche de stage ou de
Gafa est-ce que vous avez
si vous venez de Chanteloup à nos hommes
à parler ou pas ou peut-être que dans
les entreprises comme ça qui sont plus
modernes on s'en fout complètement ce
qui est pas le cas forcément des
entreprises plus classiques bah écoutez
moi j'ai pas commencé chez un gars femme
en fait j'ai commencé dans le milieu
bancaire donc c'est vrai que c'est aussi
un milieu qui est très comment dire
pardon
traditionnel mais j'étais pas dans une
banque traditionnelle j'étais dans une
banque privée libanaise donc c'est aussi
c'est c'est une autre culture
d'entreprise on va dire mais
c'est vrai qu'on a on a ce sentiment
peut-être de ne pas être comme les
autres mais je m'en suis jamais servi je
m'en suis plus servi comme une force on
va dire que qu'autre chose donc moi j'ai
pas je vais j'ai jamais eu à si vous
voulez à partir de ça modifier peut-être
mon adresse sur mon CV alors que je sais
que ça peut arriver quand on vient d'une
d'une certaine ville ça peut partir
le nom aussi peut porter préjudice mais
voilà j'ai toujours en tout cas eu coeur
à aller au-delà de ça et de me dire que
oui bah écoutez si la personne ils
estiment que je que je ne leur convient
pas du fait de ma personnalité de mon
identité j'irai voir ailleurs mais en
tout cas j'ai pas eu de personnalité
au-delà des clivages mais voilà je dis
ça aujourd'hui parce que moi en fait mon
père c'est une personne qui a qui était
éboueur en fait à la ville de Paris donc
je viens d'un milieu modeste et même si
il était pas lecteur enfin mais c'est
même si mes parents n'étaient pas
lecteurs en tout cas ils ont toujours
donné cette envie de voilà de faire ce
qu'on a envie de faire et de voilà de
pas avoir à subir en fait vous êtes
resté vous le disiez dans une famille
unie c'est ça absolument et dans aussi
moi au départ oui après mes parents se
sont séparés mais j'ai toujours continué
à avoir mon père et enfin tout comme
Pina franchement ma mère elle m'a
vraiment toujours donné en fait
cette force en fait de toujours aller
plus loin et de dépasser le fait d'être
juste une enfant de banlieue en fait
donc ça m'a beaucoup aidé et ça m'aide
toujours et ça motive en fait pour la
suite
tout à l'heure est-ce que vous la faire
marquer parfois vous une enfant de
banlieue on ne l'a pas vraiment fait
remarquer je pense que le nom de
Chanteloup est réside toujours dans
certains esprits donc forcément ceux qui
lisent mon CV je suis pas avec eux je
sais pas vraiment ce qu'ils pensent il y
en a peut-être certains qui se sont dit
que ça en valait pas la peine mais moi
ça me ferait pas en tout cas
l'énergie
finale après donc vous êtes engagés
politiquement puisque je disais vous
êtes adjointe au maire on cherche de la
jeunesse
c'était quoi pour vous cette cette forme
d'engagement écoutez moi déjà avant
d'être engagé politiquement j'étais
parents d'élèves j'ai en fait ce que
j'ai oublié de dire c'est que j'ai quand
même j'ai trois enfants en fait voilà
j'ai trois garçons et j'ai 14 ans non
j'ai mon plus grand qui va avoir 17 ans
donc j'en ai un au lycée j'en ai au
collège et j'en ai en maternelle et si
vous voulez être déjà engagé en tant que
parents je trouve que c'est important
parce que ça permet en tout cas de voilà
de voir comment on peut suivre la
scolarité de de nos enfants voir je veux
dire ce qu'on peut apporter en tant que
contribution enfin voilà ça peut être
des choses simples mais en tout cas le
la relation avec l'école je trouve que
c'est quelque chose de voilà
d'indispensable donc moi j'ai été déjà
engagée en tant par an donc pendant plus
d'une dizaine d'années après j'ai eu la
chance en fait d'être conseil citoyens
de la ville de Chanteloup parce qu'il y
a un conseil citoyen conseil citoyen
c'est quoi c'est voilà qui c'était mis
en place en 2015 dans le cadre de
contrat de ville et c'est vrai que moi
j'étais déjà assez porté en tout cas sur
les sujets qui étaient relatifs à la
jeunesse à la scolarité et voilà en tout
cas à l'égalité des chances parce que je
trouve que aujourd'hui avoir des enfants
qui sont pas lecteurs ou qui ont des
lacunes voilà c'est c'est juste pas
possible en tout cas faut voir en tout
cas ce qui peut être mis en oeuvre pour
pouvoir les aider les accompagner et je
sais que sur la commune en tout cas il y
a pas mal de choses qui sont mises en
oeuvre par le biais de la réussite
éducative et par le tissu aussi
associatif donc voilà je trouve que
c'est la combinaison de tous ces
éléments en tout cas qui fait que ça
peut ça peut contribuer même s'il y a
des enfants qu'on n'arrive pas à toucher
mais en tout cas le but c'est de voilà
de voir de toucher le maximum et de
renverser la tendance pour que l'égalité
des chances justement elle soit à tous
les niveaux et pas pas que que réservé à
certains quoi alors il y a quand même un
mal souvent dans
qui est pointé du doigt dans les
quartiers c'est le le fait que les gens
ne s'intéressent pas à la politique et
ne votent pas par exemple or on sait que
les politiques ils comprennent qu'une
chose c'est le raquette électorale
est-ce que il y a des initiatives qui
sont mises en place ici justement pour
que les jeunes s'impliquent pas qui
d'ailleurs qui soit que simple et
lecteurs parce que c'est bien d'aller
voter de temps en temps pour des gens
mais pour qui s'impliquent aussi en
politique et qui comprennent les enjeux
est-ce que vous avez des ignaties des
initiatives en fait on a je crois que ça
doit faire peut-être trois ans ou 4 ans
on a le CME donc le conseil municipal
des enfants qui existent donc c'est à
dire qu'on sensibilise les les jeunes de
CM2 de CM1 et CM2 voilà au fait de de
mener des projets qui peuvent être sur
différents portés sur différents thèmes
en fait la solidarité la culture
les seniors et en fait voilà il y a un
groupe d'enfants qui est élu par qui
sont élus par leurs camarades
par par école en fait et c'est axé sur
la parité c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'il
y ait une fille et un garçon il faut
leur montrer que voilà un moment donné
il y a il y a toute une procédure en
tout cas qui se fait comme dans le cadre
d'élection normale et c'est une façon je
pense aussi de sensibiliser dès le plus
jeune âge en tout cas à voilà à ce sens
à cette citoyenneté et voir comment en
tout cas ils peuvent ils peuvent après
évoluer dans la dans la sphère après ils
sont ils sont pas obligés de continuer
en fait mais en tout cas ça leur donne
une première impression et là je sais
qu'on ambitionne aussi de mettre en
place un CMJ donc un conseil municipal
des jeunes et pareil qui sera qui
s'adressera à une tranche un peu plus
âgée après pour le problème de du du
vote enfin de l'absence de l'absentéisme
je pense que il y a pas mal de gens qui
sont peut-être bah qui comprennent
peut-être pas toujours les messages en
tout cas de de nos politiques et il y a
peut-être en tout cas quelque chose à
faire là-dessus pour réinstaurer en tout
cas le débat le débat autour des de
certaines valeurs ou certaines notions
alors là vous sentez-vous attirer par
justement cette
avoir des des je sais pas un rôle dans
la vie de la cité
et bien moi je pense que ça pourrait
être vraiment une bonne idée le conseil
municipal des jeunes parce que c'est
vrai que les jeunes de notre âge enfin
moi j'ai 18 ans on n'est pas on se sent
vraiment pas impliqué dans tout ce qui
est politique etc et c'est vrai c'est
pas qu'on comprend pas vraiment le
message mais en fait on cherche en fait
cet appartement en fait un parti ou à
une personne politique tout simplement
en fait quelqu'un qui nous prend en
compte en fait dans son discours parce
que oui parce que le vrai défi il est là
ce sont ceux qui sont éloignés de de la
chose publique en tant que telle c'est
pas c'est vrai qu'il faut faire un vrai
travail à l'école pour pour qu'il y ait
dès le plus jeune à cette culture et
surtout que souvent dans les familles
d'ailleurs il y a pas cette culture
politique elle dit d'ailleurs elle est
souvent présente mais elle est présente
à travers les les émissions les parents
souvent ils parlent de ça mais pas en
tant que lecteur et du coup c'est pas un
geste naturel et et l'école joue un rôle
mais ce public est un peu éloigné est-ce
que vous pensez pas qu'il y a quelque
chose à faire justement et quels sont
les
quels sont les les éléments quels sont
qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre
pour aller chercher justement ces jeunes
d'après vous vous qui avez 18 ans par
exemple les les gens qui ne
s'intéressent pas à grand chose comment
on va les chercher comment on peut aller
leur parler vous intéresser à ça moi je
pense que déjà il faudrait commencer ça
au collège enfin à l'école élémentaire
et au collège surtout parce que là on
est un âge où voilà on est capable de
raisonner seul et d'avoir un esprit
critique
au collège
ça va ça va
on a des cours d'éducation morale et
civique donc ça c'est déjà bien on est
censé en fait se rapprocher en fait de
de le futur citoyen en fait qu'on va
être plus tard et je pense qu'il devrait
être un peu plus approfondi quand même
parce qu'on
n'y est pas encore justement vous êtes à
droite la jeunesse c'est quoi les
demandes au fond de des jeunes de
Chanteloup mais justement moi à ce
niveau là bon là ça fait que deux ans on
va dire je suis sur le mandat j'ai pas
encore enfin il y a des défis en tout
cas que je me que que j'ai encore et que
j'aimerais bien relever c'est justement
voir quel pourrait être les choses en
tout cas qui sont du sens pour pour
cette jeunesse et et voir les en tout
cas les directions vers lesquelles on
pourrait évoluer pour que ça pour qu'il
y a des choses qui leur parle parce que
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on met pas mal
de choses en place peut-être pour les
enfin pour les plus jeunes pour ceux qui
sont au niveau des des ados mais au
niveau de
les plus âgés on a toute la partie
emploi et insertion où on fait de
l'accompagnement effectivement sur leur
au niveau de l'orientation ou au niveau
de l'insertion professionnelle pour ceux
qui sont aussi en décrochage scolaire ou
des choses comme ça mais après pour ce
qui est des projets hautes en tout cas
moi je compte sur les personnes comme
Dalanda pour pour être source de
proposition et dans une proposition pour
voir justement pour qu'on fasse des
choses qui leur plaisent et pas qu'ils
subissent en fait parce que c'est sinon
ça a pas ça pas d'intérêt
on a l'impression que je comment on
appelle les habitants de Chanteloup
l'échantillon
vous êtes des chanteuses heureuse
on va dire oui on va dire oui on est on
est encore là donc je pense que sinon ce
serait déjà parti sinon vous serez déjà
parti absolument et vous dites il y a on
en parlait avec Pierre Cardot avec
il y a parfois aussi une fierté d'être
dissident il y a un attachement aussi
après je pense avec les gens et du fait
de la taille de la de la ville aussi
c'est ce qui fait ça je veux dire tout
le monde a enfin tout le monde se
connaît pratiquement et c'est vrai que
nous on avait cette facilité à passer
d'un d'une place à l'autre qu'on était
enfin moi quand j'étais plus petite
parce qu'il y avait pas de il y avait
pas de route
traversante ou dangereuse et c'est vrai
que forcément en tout cas il y avait ce
sentiment de de de sécurité de de ma
part et après je veux dire c'est comme
partout il y a forcément des des des
problèmes mais bon ça c'est pas du fait
de notre de notre commune c'est voilà
c'est la conjoncture je pense est-ce que
vous avez pas eu envie à un moment donné
de partir d'ici pour vos enfants par
exemple
non parce qu'en fait moi si vous voulez
je suis très attaché à ma famille moi
j'aimais parents qui habitent pas très
loin qui sont à proximité et
au-delà de ça non j'ai voilà j'ai
souhaité en tout cas privilégier ma
famille que de partir ailleurs et je
veux dire moi j'ai fréquenté comme je
vous disais les enfin l'école publique
enfin de toute ma scolarité et mes
enfants continuent à le faire j'ai pas
j'ai pas eu j'ai pas j'étais pas mis
dans ce que j'aurais pu faire aussi mais
voilà je pense que en tout cas quand on
fréquente des enfants issus de
différents de divers horizons on apprend
on apprend de l'autre et ça c'est vrai
c'est une vraie richesse
voilà Monsieur ce que voilà c'est ce que
certains d'entre nous on essaye de
défendre depuis
des années dans les médias et et bien
que qui est des gens qui vivent les
choses qui disent aussi aux autres donc
merci beaucoup pour ces beaux
témoignages
[Musique]